[Music]
this morning we bring you two slices of
american history one
presidential the other edible plymouth
cheese was formed in vermont by the
father of our 30th president kelvin
coolidge
in the building next door plymouth is
also the place where coolidge was sworn
in
famously in the middle of the night
after his predecessor died suddenly
one part of plymouth the presidential
site has barely changed at all since
1890. the same can't be said for
plymouth cheese which has gone through
its shares of ups and downs
but is now shepherded by a husband and
wife team who have brought back
its glory days while setting a path
forward for other artisans
and farmers across the country why
cheese
it's a time capsule it's more than a
piece of cheese it's a piece of
american history a dozen years ago jesse
warner took
on a monumental job revive the nation's
second oldest cheese factory plymouth
cheese
so it's interesting with cheese because
we have to be thinking like what was it
like one year ago when we made this
cheese
especially artisan cheese what were the
cows eating that day
what was the temperature what was the
humidity it all has an effect
oh it's like the cheese you normally
have but way better
thanks
werner uses original recipes from 1890
when john calvin coolidge senior
established the company in the same
building werner still uses today
at this place history farming and food
converge that was film footage taken in
the summer of 1924
in the building just a stone's throw
from plymouth cheese
john's son calvin coolidge was sworn in
as the nation's 30th president in the
middle of the night
by kerosene lamp after warren g harding
died
suddenly this bible lay on the table
under my hand when i took the oath of
office as president
august 3rd 1923 calvin coolidge
all these buildings have been carefully
preserved
bill jenny is the regional historic site
administrator
everything we're seeing now walking down
this road is as
kelvin coolidge saw it right it really
is like walking back in time
it is especially in the early evening
you can walk down the street and almost
imagine
coolidge right beside you what does it
mean to have
the cheese factory back cheese factory
is a great part of the historic site
cheese making in vermont was born from
necessity
farmers had no way to get the milk they
produced to cities without its spoiling
so they turned what they couldn't sell
into cheese to extend its shelf life
as pasteurization the process of
neutralizing potentially harmful
bacteria
and refrigerated trucks became standard
locally produced dairy could now reach
entire regions of the country from there
mass production took over
and by a generation ago local cheese
making here
was almost lost forever cheese making in
vermont effectively
disappeared and then has now come back
to the point where more cheese is being
made in vermont than
per capita than any other place in the
country how did that happen
i think we've had a real food
renaissance recently
certainly it started happening with a
lot of back to the landers in the 80s
including your parents yeah werner grew
up on a small
farm in northern vermont in 2009 he
leased the old coolidge building from
the states
and began rebuilding plymouth cheese bit
by bit
today he and his wife sarit run an
operation that is bursting in popularity
every detail is authentic from the taste
to the throwback packaging
these stencils are actually from the
turn of the century i was very inspired
by
this graphic language and so we built
upon that to make our new cheese boxes
it is a far cry from syritz days working
in the new york city fashion industry
as i like to say the fashion snobs have
nothing on the cheese snobs but
fashion snobs have nothing on the cheese
snobs but it's a great no people
care very deeply about about um being a
part of
um the the artisan economy of
of this country and and so do we but the
people the chief snobs who are coming
here i mean
some people just pulled up i mean
they're not the people who are buying
five thousand dollar oscar de la renta
dresses right
they just want quality food they want
quality food they want real food they
want quality food they care where their
food
comes from who's making it and you know
what they can taste the love and the
passion that goes into this
how's it going good in plymouth warner
has gone out of his way to support
local dairy farms including the one
owned by
seth leach who was a seventh generation
farmer
if it wasn't for him what would happen
to you
my my path would be a little tougher
moving forward for sure
tougher as in you may have had to
shuttle the farm oh yeah
thanks let me know about next week the
trends in dairy farming nationwide
are not good which is why it's so
remarkable to see a business
like this succeed against the odds a lot
of people don't understand
how cheese is made it's quite simple at
its root it only there's only four
ingredients
in cheese it's milk culture
salt and enzymes and out of those four
ingredients
you can make thousands of different
types of cheese so what part of the
process are we in now
this is toward the end it's like he's
making fries
yeah they look like french fries yeah
yeah this is the part when we're
starting to add the salt salt is very
important for cheese making
for preserving and for flavor i never
knew what a workout making cheese is
this is the fun part and by fun you mean
it's like one of those things you name
for the opposite
some people i think stay away from
cheese because they don't think it's the
healthiest option
no it's definitely the healthiest option
it is it is
raw milk whole milk cheese is definitely
the healthiest option
okay i mean it's a it's a true
expression of the natural environment
it's full of probiotics it's full of
amino acids
proteins and fats and all kinds of
naturally occurring bacteria that you
only find
in nature
while there are plenty of arguments for
and against raw milk and the bacteria
found in it
like with any food cheese is probably
best consumed
in moderation today werner has expanded
to produce
a dozen varieties of plymouth cheese
all while staying loyal to a legacy
you're keeping things traditional while
moving forward
that's the idea is you know use these
techniques and these traditions
and make a product that that was quality
at the time
and try to bring that into the future
and share that with people that
don't necessarily live right here in
plymouth
best of both worlds right fantastic and
we have uh we have a
a large sampling yes yes uh i think you
have the
plymouth original plymouth right here
um but also we have delicious right east
meadow
garlic peppercorn hot pepper you're
gonna take some hot pepper i'm
definitely saying
i'll take any i'll take any and all um
black truffle here
oh yeah that too is the older ones
they're aged between 90 days and two
years they're delicious
yeah i mean cheeses i know well
it's also better with wine cheers cheers
cheers
cheers good story and i like you getting
down and dirty helping them out and
that's right
hair was all over the place looking a
little
more clumped there jeff works what do
you think